Bonjour à tous !
Aujourd'hui, on va parler
du plus grand mystère de la physique fondamentale,
celui qui empêche
des milliers  de chercheurs de dormir.
Ce qu'on appelle prétentieusement
"la théorie du tout".
La théorie du tout, c'est supposément
la réunion de l'infiniment grand
et de l'infiniment petit,
l'unification de la théorie de la relativité générale
avec la mécanique quantique.
D'ailleurs, on appelle ça plus simplement
"le problème de la gravité quantique".
Alors il y a une approche très connue à ce problème,
c'est la théorie des cordes.
(J'ai déjà eu l'occasion de faire une vidéo sur ce sujet.)
Mais aujourd'hui,
je voudrais vous  parler de l'autre théorie,
celle qui est moins connue que la théorie des cordes mais qui, personnellement, a ma préférence :
la gravité quantique à boucles.
*jingle très funky*
Le problème de la gravité quantique,
c'est celui de l'unification de deux théories
qui dans la première moitié du XXe siècle
ont complètement bouleversé notre vision du monde.
La première de ces théories, c'est la relativité générale,
le chef-d'oeuvre d'Albert Einstein,
et c'est une théorie de la force de gravité.
Avant Einstein, on avait déjà une théorie
de la force de gravité, celle de Newton,
qui était là depuis presque 250 ans.
Et c'est celle qu'on apprend à l'école,
"deux corps massifs s'attirent
parce  qu'il y existe une force entre les deux"
et Newton nous donne même la formule
qui permet de calculer cette force.
La théorie de Newton, elle est fabuleuse,
elle marche fantastiquement bien
depuis plus de 3 siècles maintenant.
C'est celle qui permet de comprendre
à la fois la chute des corps,
mais aussi le mouvement des planètes.
Je sais pas si vous réalisez
le tour de force que ça représente pour l'époque.
Newton comprend
que ce qui fait tomber une pomme vers le sol
et ce qui explique le mouvement
d'une planète autour du soleil,
c'est la même chose.
(Un truc de dingue !)
Il y a une citation de Paul Valéry
que j'aime beaucoup et qui résume bien ça :
__
Bref, la théorie de Newton ça marche hyper bien.
Et là, Einstein arrive et propose de la remplacer
par quelque chose
de conceptuellement complètement différent.
Pour Einstein, si les corps s'attirent,
c'est pas parce qu'il existe une force invisible entre eux,
mais parce qu'ils déforment l'espace-temps.
L'image classique, c'est celle d'un drap tendu
sur lequel on poserait des objets.
Et c'est la courbure de l'espace-temps
qui modifie la trajectoire des corps massifs
et provoque leur attraction.
Il y a une chose qu'il faut bien avoir en tête :
Ll théorie d'Einstein, mathématiquement,
elle est très différente de celle de Newton,
mais ses résultats, ses prédictions physiques,
sont essentiellement les mêmes.
Bah oui encore heureux, on l'a dit la théorie
de Newton marche extrêmement bien,
donc la théorie d'Einstein elle a quand même
plutôt intérêt à donner les mêmes résultats.
Si vous vous amusez à calculer la chute d'une
pomme ou la trajectoire de la Lune autour de la Terre,
avec la théorie de la relativité générale, vous allez trouver la même chose qu'avec la théorie de Newton.
Sauf...
Sauf quand le champ gravitationnel
devient vraiment intense.
Par exemple Mercure, qui est beaucoup
plus proche du Soleil que la Terre,
elle est dans un champ de gravité plus intense.
Et là, le calcul de sa trajectoire par Newton et par Einstein donnent des résultats légèrement différents.
Et c'est le calcul d'Einstein qui
colle avec les observations.
C'est à dire que la théorie de la relativité générale,
elle améliore la théorie de Newton
en particulier pour les champs gravitationnels intenses.
Et elle va même jusqu'à prédire l'existence d'objets qui n'existaient pas dans la théorie de Newton comme par exemple les trous noirs.
Des régions de l'espace-temps d'où rien ne peut s'échapper, même pas la lumière.
Et puis bien sûr,  une des prédictions les plus spectaculaires de la théorie de la relativité générale,
c'est le Big Bang.
La théorie du Big Bang, elle découle de
l'application des équations d'Einstein
à l'univers tout entier.
Et elle nous prédit que l'univers n'est
pas une sorte d'arène statique,
mais peut être quelque chose qui est en
train de se dilater ou de se contracter.
Et c'est ce qui a été observé pour la première
fois par Edwin Hubble dans les années 20,
et puis par plein d'autres gens après lui :
toutes les galaxies de l'univers
s'éloignent les unes des autres.
Un peu comme un drap élastique sur
lequel on serait en train de tirer de tous les côtés.
Si on utilise les équations de la cosmologie pour remonter dans le passé de l'univers,
on voit que plus on remonte dans le temps,
plus l'univers était contracté, dense et chaud.
Jusqu'à il y a 13,8 milliards d'années,
où d'après les équations,
l'univers était un point infiniment dense.
(Un peu comme si il était né à ce moment-là.)
C'est un peu bizarre comme conclusion, nan?
Et on va voir dans la suite ce qu'il faut en penser.
*jingle très funky*
L'autre immense révolution du début du 20ème siècle, c'est la mécanique quantique.
La mécanique quantique, c'est un peu le contraire de la relativité générale,
c'est une théorie de l'infiniment petit.
C'est celle qui permet de comprendre comment se comporte la matière au niveau des molécules, des atomes,
et puis, plus petits : des protons, des neutrons
et toutes les particules élémentaires.
Si on doit la relativité générale
presque exclusivement à Einstein,
la mécanique quantique, elle, est
vraiment le fruit d'un effort collectif,
d'une série de génies qui
ont travaillé entre 1900 et 1930.
Vous voyez ici la mythique photo du
Congrès Solvay de 1927.
Tous les fondateurs de la mécanique quantique sont là,
et sur les vingt-neuf personnes présentes,
dix-sept ont eu le prix Nobel.
Alors il n'y a qu'une seule femme dans l'assemblée, c'est Marie Curie, mais enfin elle, elle l'a eu deux fois.
Ce que nous dit la mécanique quantique,
c'est qu'à très petite échelle
la matière se comporte différemment de ce
dont on a l'habitude à notre échelle.
Et le mieux pour s'en rendre compte, c'est
considérer un atome d'hydrogène.
Un atome d'hydrogène, en apparence c'est simple :
un proton, chargé positivement, et
un électron, chargé négativement.
Et entre eux existe une force : la force électrostatique de Coulomb,
qui dit que les charges opposées s'attirent.
Cette force, elle ressemble beaucoup à la force de Newton, et elle nous dit que l'électron doit tourner autour du proton.
Cette description est simple, mais elle a un petit problème :
comme l'électron peut perdre de l'énergie,
il va se mettre à tourner de plus en plus bas
de plus en plus proche du proton
jusqu'à venir s'écraser sur lui.
Un peu comme un satellite peut rentrer
dans l'atmosphère.
Si ça c'était vrai, les atomes d'hydrogène seraient instable, or, on voit bien qu'ils sont stables.
La mécanique quantique va résoudre ce problème
en venant modifier la vision qu'on a
de l'atome d'hydrogène.
Tout d'abord, la mécanique quantique nous dit que l'électron n'a pas une trajectoire bien définie,
il n'est pas en un point précis de l'espace sur
un point bien défini de son orbite.
Il est dans une superposition d'états comme s'il était un peu partout sur son orbite à la fois.
L'autre grand changement, c'est que l'électron
ne peut plus se trouver n'importe où,
il n'a que certains niveaux d'énergie possibles.
Ce qu'on symbolise souvent en faisant
comme s'il n'avait que
certaines orbites possibles,
même si c'est pas tout à fait ça.
L'électron peut être dans un certain niveau, dans le niveau suivant, mais pas entre les deux.
Et du coup on leur met des numéros :
niveau 1, niveau 2, niveau 3.
On dit que les niveaux d'énergie sont "quantifiés".
Et c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça la
mécanique "quantique".
Alors cette quantification des niveaux d'énergie
elle a deux conséquences.
La première, c'est qu'un électron peut
sauter d'un niveau d'énergie à un autre
en émettant ou en absorbant une quantité
d'énergie bien déterminée
sous la forme de lumière de longueur
d'onde bien définie.
Et ça on le vérifie tous les jours avec la couleur
de la lumière qui est absorbée
ou émise par les différents atomes.
L'autre conséquence, c'est que l'électron ne peut pas descendre plus bas en énergie que le niveau 1,
qu'on appelle "niveau fondamental",
et en particulier ça l'empêche
d'aller s'écraser sur le proton.
Tout se passe comme si il y avait une espèce de force de répulsion due aux effets quantiques
qui protégeait l'atome de l'instabilité.
Et on va voir que ça va jouer un rôle
important dans notre affaire.
*jingle funky*
Relativité générale et mécanique
quantique,
les deux énormes révolutions du 20ème siècle
en physique fondamentale.
Et jusqu'à aujourd'hui, ces deux théories ont fonctionné merveilleusement bien.
On l'a vu encore récemment avec la découverte des ondes gravitationnelles pour la relativité générale
et la découverte du Boson de Higgs pour
la mécanique quantique.
Et pourtant ces deux théories, elles sont
complètement incompatibles.
La relativité générale nous décrit un monde qui est courbé mais lisse, déterministe.
À côté de ça, la mécanique quantique nous dit que, au niveau microscopique, le monde est discret, probabiliste, fluctuant.
C'est d'ailleurs assez bien reflété dans les outils mathématiques qui sont utilisés par les deux théories
qui sont complètement différents.
Deux théories aussi bien vérifiées mais qui sont incompatibles,
les physiciens théoriciens détestent.
Si on pouvait remplacer ça par une seule théorie qui engloberait les deux, ça serait quand même vachement mieux.
Il faut voir que la volonté d'unifier ensemble
des phénomènes
a toujours été un puissant moteur de compréhension.
Il y a l'exemple que j'ai donné tout à l'heure de Newton
qui unifie le mouvement de la chute des corps avec celui du mouvement des planètes.
Mais il y a un autre exemple encore plus fou :
James Maxwell, qui à la fin du 19ème
siècle découvre l'électromagnétisme.
Il montre que l'électricité et le magnétisme des aimants ne sont que deux aspects d'un truc plus fondamental :
le champ électromagnétique.
Et quelques années plus tard, il comprend que la lumière est une onde du champ électromagnétique.
C'est-à-dire que d'un coup Maxwell unifie trois trucs qui avant étaient considérés comme indépendants :
l'électricité, le magnétisme et la
lumière.
Et ça lui permet d'ailleurs de
comprendre qu'il doit exister
d'autres ondes électromagnétiques
que la lumière visible.
Et bah on les connaît aujourd'hui : les micro-ondes, les ondes radio, les rayons X.
Bref, unifier des phénomènes, c'est un
peu la classe mondiale en physique théorique.
Alors on pourrait rétorquer que unifier la relativité générale et la mécanique quantique,
on s'en fout un peu.
On l'a dit, la relativité générale,
c'est une théorie des objets très lourds.
À côté de ça, la mécanique quantique,
c'est une théorie des objets très petits.
Bah les objets très lourds, en général,
ils ne sont pas très petits..
Ouais, sauf qu'il y a deux exceptions à cette règle.
La première, c'est ce qui se passe au
centre des trous noirs.
D'après la relativité générale, toute
la matière qui tombe dans un trou noir
va se concentrer en son centre,
en un point infinitésimal,
un truc très lourd et très petit.
C'est ce qu'on appelle une "singularité".
Autre singularité, les premiers
instants du Big Bang.
On a vu tout à l'heure que si on utilisait
les équations de la cosmologie,
on arrivait à cette conclusion un petit peu étrange
que, il y a 13,8 milliards d'années,
l'univers aurait été
un point infiniment dense.
Oui, sauf qu'en fait on n'en sait rien.
Puisque là on avait affaire à quelque chose qui était
à la fois très lourd et très petit.
Donc on ne peut pas juste utiliser les
équations de la relativité générale,
il faut prendre en compte aussi la
mécanique quantique,
il nous faut une théorie unifiée.
Pour comprendre les premiers instants du Big Bang,
il nous faut une théorie de la gravité quantique.
Bon ok assez papoté, on la fabrique
cette théorie la gravité quantique ?
*jingle très funky*
Pour comprendre comment on peut
construire une théorie la gravité quantique,
il faut bien réaliser que la relativité générale et
la mécanique quantique qu'on veut unifier,
ce sont deux théories qui ne se situent
pas vraiment sur le même plan.
La relativité générale, c'est une
théorie qui décrit une force,
la "force de gravité" (on devrait d'ailleurs plutôt
dire une "interaction").
En gros, on peut la comparer à la force
électromagnétique.
La mécanique quantique, c'est pas
une force, c'est plutôt
un ensemble de principes qui nous disent comment une force va se comporter au niveau microscopique.
On l'a vu tout à l'heure avec l'exemple de l'atome d'hydrogène :
on a la vision classique qui ne marche pas
et la mécanique quantique vient modifier
cette vision pour nous dire comment
les choses se passent à petite échelle.
Donc il ne s'agit pas tellement d'unifier
la mécanique quantique et la relativité générale,
mais plutôt d'arriver à appliquer les principes de la mécanique quantique à la théorie de la relativité générale.
Habituellement, on dit qu'il existe
quatre forces fondamentales dans la nature :
l'électromagnétisme - qui explique
quasiment tout ce qu'on voit autour de nous -
les forces nucléaires forte et faible - qui assurent notamment la cohésion des noyaux atomiques -
et la gravité - décrite par la
relativité générale.
Et on peut faire avec ces forces ce
qu'on a fait avec l'atome d'hydrogène,
c'est-à-dire leur appliquer les
principes de la mécanique quantique.
Et comme ça on peut par exemple passer
de l'électromagnétisme à sa version quantique
ce qu'on appelle
l' "électrodynamique quantique".
On peut faire ça aussi avec la force nucléaire forte
et on obtient la "chromodynamique quantique"
et avec la force nucléaire faible.
Ces trois forces dans leurs versions
quantiques forment ce qu'on appelle
"le modèle standard de la physique des particules".
Parce que tout ce qu'on comprend aujourd'hui du comportement des particules élémentaires
s'explique par ce modèle.
Tout ce qu'on voit dans les accélérateurs de particules jusqu'à la découverte du Boson de Higgs au CERN
s'explique par le "modèle standard".
Alors, appliquer les principes de la
mécanique quantique, ça a marché avec
les trois premières forces.
Bah il n'y a plus qu'à faire ça avec la
quatrième : la relativité générale.
Ouais, sauf que c'est là que ça se corse...
Je ne vous ai pas dit comment on fait pour passer
d'une théorie à sa version quantique.
Cette opération s'appelle la
"quantification"
et il existe une sorte de procédure
pour la faire.
Elle a été décrite par un des grands
génies de la mécanique quantique :
Paul Dirac.
Dirac a proposé une sorte de recette
de cuisine qui permet de prendre une
théorie classique
et de fabriquer la théorie quantique
correspondante.
Il y a deux problèmes avec cette recette.
Le premier, c'est qu'elle nous demande
de construire des objets mathématiques
qui sont beaucoup plus compliqués
que ce qu'on avait au départ
et donc l'arsenal mathématique à utiliser peut
devenir vite assez effrayant.
L'autre problème, c'est que la recette de Dirac,
elle est vague.
Elle nous dit ce dont on a besoin, mais elle ne nous dit pas comment faire pour le trouver.
Si on applique cette recette à l'atome d'hydrogène
on trouve la théorie quantique de l'atome d'hydrogène,
mais si on essaye de l'appliquer à l'électromagnétisme, et bien ça coince déjà.
Dans le cas de l'électromagnétisme,
cette difficulté a été contournée
en se limitant à des situations où les
champs ne sont pas trop intenses.
Ou bien, une autre manière de le dire, où il n'y a
pas trop de particules qui interagissent.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'approche perturbative.
C'est un peu comme si vous vouliez
comprendre les mouvements de la mer
et que vous décidiez prudemment de
vous limiter à l'étude des vagues,
mais en ignorant les phénomènes plus globaux
comme les courants ou les tempêtes.
L'approche perturbative, elle est par exemple
suffisante pour comprendre
ce qu'il se passe dans les accélérateurs de particules.
Et cette approche, on la doit notamment
à un autre grand génie de la physique quantique :
Richard Feynman.
Feynman a notamment introduit un outil
qui maintenant porte son nom :
les diagrammes de Feynman.
Il s'agit de petits dessins qui représentent
les interactions entre les particules,
et si vous ouvrez un livre de physique des particules,
vous en verrez à quasiment toutes les pages.
Alors pourquoi je vous raconte tout ça ?
Et bien parce que la raison fondatrice qui fait que
construire une théorie de la gravité
quantique c'est compliqué,
c'est que l'approche perturbative ne marche
pas avec la relativité générale.
Si vous essayez quand même d'appliquer
l'approche perturbative à la relativité générale,
vous allez toujours trouver l'infini. C'est-à-dire
que vous allez construire une théorie
qui quelque soit la question que vous lui
posez va vous répondre l'infini.
Pas très pratique.
Ce résultat c'est vraiment l'acte de
naissance des différentes approches au
problème de la gravité quantique, parce
qu'on avait une méthode
- la méthode perturbative -
qui a très bien marché pour les trois
premières forces
- l'électromagnétisme, force nucléaire
faible et force nucléaire forte -
mais qui ne marche pas avec la
relativité générale.
Donc il faut trouver autre chose.
Et à partir de là, le monde se divise
en deux catégories :
ceux qui décident de s'accrocher à
l'approche perturbative
et ceux qui décident de l'abandonner.
Alors je ne vais pas vous reparler aujourd'hui
de la théorie des cordes,
j'ai déjà fait un épisode dessus.
Mais ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est qu'en
théorie des cordes,
on essaie de préserver l'approche perturbative.
Et pour ça, on change un peu les
postulats de départ, et ça se fait
au prix de l'introduction de quelques
petits trucs exotiques comme
des minuscules cordes,
des dimensions supplémentaires
et puis un certain nombre de particules
nouvelles : les particules supersymétriques.
Une bonne partie de ceux qui ont voulu
essayer autre chose que la théorie des cordes
ont décidé de laisser tomber l'approche perturbative
et de revenir à la recette initiale
de Dirac.
Et c'est une des origines de la gravité
quantique à boucles.
Mais avant de vous parler de ça,
il faut que je vous explique
pourquoi les chercheurs de ce domaine
ont de bonnes raisons de penser que
la méthode perturbative
ne pouvait de toute façon pas fonctionner.
Toute la philosophie de la relativité
générale, c'est que l'espace-temps n'existe plus
en tant qu'arène fixe dans lequel
se dérouleraient les choses,
mais l'espace-temps est un objet
lui-même changeant, dynamique.
Il y a une jolie phrase qui résume ça :
"En relativité générale, la scène
disparaît et devient un des acteurs."
Quand vous voulez faire une approche
perturbative, vous êtes obligé de réintroduire
une sorte de scène figée sur laquelle
se produisent les perturbations.
Et pour les puristes de la relativité générale,
ça trahit un de ces principes fondamentaux
et donc c'est pas étonnant que ça ne
fonctionne pas bien.
Ok très bien, mais comment on fait pour
appliquer le programme de quantification
de Dirac à la relativité générale
sans utiliser les perturbations ?
Et bien, c'est dur...
Et c'est tellement dur que personne
n'a jamais réussi
...jusqu'en 1986.
*jingle très funky*
En 1986, un physicien indien, Abhay Ashtekar,
propose quelque chose de nouveau.
Il propose de reformuler la théorie de
la relativité générale.
C'est-à-dire qu'il prend les équations d'Einstein
et il les ré-écrit différemment.
Mathématiquement, les variables et
les équations qu'il utilise sont différentes,
mais physiquement c'est la
même théorie.
Elle est équivalente à la relativité
générale, elle fait les mêmes prédictions.
Mais sa nouvelle forme la fait ressembler
un peu plus à l'électromagnétisme.
Et c'est ça qui va débloquer
l'application du programme de Dirac.
Ça, et puis les boucles bien sûr.
Alors ce qui va venir est un peu technique,
mais je suis quand même obligé de vous expliquer
d'où vient le terme de "boucles"
dans la gravité quantique à boucles.
On a vu que la théorie de la relativité générale porte
sur la courbure de l'espace-temps,
mais comment on fait pour savoir qu'on
est dans un espace-temps courbé?
Parce qu'on est dedans, donc c'est pas
forcément facile de s'en rendre compte.
Et bien, on fait des boucles.
Imaginez que vous soyez sur un plan, et que vous
teniez à la main une flèche
- par exemple une flèche d'arc devant vous.
Déplacez-vous tout droit pendant un
moment puis arrêtez-vous
et prenez un virage à 90 degrés sans
changer la position de la flèche.
Continuez à marcher tout droit, puis
recommencez à faire un virage à 90 degrés
sans bouger la flèche, et ainsi
de suite jusqu'à votre position initiale.
À la fin, la flèche est dans la
même position qu'au départ.
Maintenant on va jouer au même jeu sur
une sphère, qui est un espace courbe.
Déplacez-vous tout droit,
puis tournez à angle droit sans
changer la direction de la flèche,
avancez,
tournez à nouveau sans changer
la direction de la flèche,
puis revenez à votre point initial.
Et bien là, la flèche n'est plus dans la
même direction qu'au départ,
et ça c'est le signe qu'un espace est
courbe.
Quand dans un espace courbe on fait une boucle, c'est-à-dire un tour et qu'on revient à son point de départ,
les vecteurs se retrouvent dans une
position différente.
Alors tout ça peut vous paraître
affreusement abstrait, mais ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que faire des boucles ça
permet de sentir la courbure de l'espace-temps,
ça permet même de la mesurer en fait.
Et donc en remplaçant la notion de
courbure par la notion de boucle,
on arrive à débloquer la situation
et à appliquer le programme de Dirac
à la relativité générale reformulée
par Ashtekar.
Alors évidemment je ne vais pas vous
décrire toute la théorie,
mais, par analogie avec l'atome d'hydrogène, je
voudrais vous en faire sentir les résultats principaux.
Le résultat le plus spectaculaire, il a
été obtenu par deux chercheurs :
un américain, Lee Smolin,
et un italien Carlo Rovelli.
Je vous ai dit qu'un des apports de la
mécanique quantique à l'atome d'hydrogène
c'est que les niveaux
d'énergie sont quantifiés, discrets,
et notamment il existe un plus petit
niveau d'énergie.
Et bien en gravité quantique à boucles, il se passe la même chose avec la géométrie de l'espace-temps.
En gravité quantique à boucles, les
grandeurs géométriques sont
quantifiées - les longueurs, les aires, les volumes.
Il existe par exemple une plus petite aire
possible que puisse posséder une surface,
et elle peut posséder certaines valeurs discrètes pour son aire, mais pas les valeurs intermédiaires.
Alors ces dimensions géométriques
minimales, elles sont toutes petites.
La plus petite longueur est d'environ 10^(-35) mètres,
ce qu'on appelle la "longueur de Planck".
Donc, évidemment, à notre échelle on ne
voit pas la différence.
Ce que nous dit ce résultat, c'est que si on
descend à l'échelle de la longueur de Planck,
l'espace n'est plus continu
mais il est discret.
Il est fait de petits blocs indivisibles,
des sortes de briques élémentaires de taille finie,
des espèces d'atomes d'espace.
Pour représenter cette situation, on
utilise un réseau qui symbolise
la manière dont les différents atomes
d'espace sont reliés entre eux.
Ce réseau, c'est un état quantique de
la courbure de l'espace
- on appelle ça un "réseau de spins".
Une fois qu'on a compris ça, il y a une
autre question essentielle :
Comment cet espace évolue-t-il ?  C'est-à-dire,
à quoi ressemble l'espace-temps ?
On a vu dans le cas de l'atome d'hydrogène que l'électron pouvait passer d'un niveau à un autre.
Et bien ça se passe pareil avec notre
représentation quantique de l'espace,
on peut passer d'un réseau de spins à un autre.
Et pour faire ça, il suffit d'imaginer
une structure intermédiaire qui les relie
- on appelle ça une "mousse de spins".
Cette mousse de spin, c'est une
représentation quantique de l'espace-temps.
Et c'est important de comprendre que
tout ça, c'est pas juste du dessin.
En fait, derrière ces mousses de spins,
il y a des équations
qu'on associe aux différents éléments
la structure et qui permettent de décrire
la probabilité que l'espace passe d'un
état quantique à un autre.
Et je vous passe évidemment les
détails, mais ce qui reste c'est que
la gravité quantique à boucles nous
montre que l'espace-temps quantique
n'est plus un truc lisse et continu comme
en relativité générale.
Il est fait de briques élémentaires de
taille finie, quantifiées et qui sont fluctuantes
- qui peuvent sauter d'un état
à un autre -,
une sorte d'espace-temps bouillonnant.
*jingle très funky*
Je vous ai décrit à grands traits la
gravité quantique à boucles,
mais maintenant je voudrais vous
expliquer la cerise sur le gâteau :
comment cette théorie va modifier
notre vision du Big Bang ?
Dans les années 2000, il y a un jeune physicien
qui s'appelle Martin Bojowald
qui s'est amusé à appliquer les
équations de la gravité quantique à boucles
aux problèmes de la cosmologie,
et il a créé ce qu'on appelle la
cosmologie quantique à boucles.
Et je ne vais évidemment pas vous en donner
les détails, mais je voudrais juste
vous faire comprendre les leçons qu'on en tire.
La gravité quantique à boucles nous
montre que l'espace-temps est fait de
minuscules morceaux de taille finie,
des atomes d'espace-temps.
Une des conséquences de ça,
c'est qu'on ne peut pas indéfiniment
accumuler de la matière au même endroit.
Il y a une densité maximale qu'on peut
atteindre : la densité de Planck.
Cette densité, elle est monstrueuse :
c'est 5 x 10^96 kg/m3
c'est-à-dire "5" avec quatre-vingt-seize "0" derrière.
Et cette densité maximum, elle change
notre perception du Big Bang.
En cosmologie classique, quand on remonte
vers le Big Bang, la densité est de plus en plus
élevée jusqu'à devenir
soi-disant infinie.
Mais en cosmologie quantique à boucles, la
densité ne peut pas dépasser la densité de Planck,
donc quand on remonte dans le temps,
au bout d'un moment ça coince.
Et il se passe un peu la même chose
qu'avec l'électron de l'atome d'hydrogène.
Vous vous souvenez ?
L'électron ne peut pas aller s'écraser sur
le proton parce qu'il ne peut pas descendre
plus bas que le niveau fondamental, et
donc tout se passe comme si il y avait une
espèce de force de répulsion quantique qui
l'empêchait de s'approcher trop près du proton.
Et bien c'est un peu la même chose qu'on a
en cosmologie quantique à boucles, tout se passe
comme si il y avait une espèce de force de répulsion qui empêchait de dépasser la densité de Planck.
Et donc ça change notre vision des
débuts du Big Bang.
On passe d'une vision d'un Big Bang à ce qui pourrait être plus tôt un Big Bounce - un "grand rebond".
Les calculs en cosmologie quantique
à boucles nous montrent que l'univers à pu
se créer de l'effondrement d'un
univers précédent,
rebondir à la densité maximale et
s'étendre jusqu'à donner notre univers.
Alors c'est encore spéculatif et les
équations sont assez simplifiées,
mais ça fait partie des possibilités.
Alors, mauvaise nouvelle ou bonne
nouvelle, les calculs montrent que le rebond
a effacé toutes les traces du passé dans un
espèce de grand bouillonnement quantique.
C'est-à-dire que, même si ça se révèle
confirmé un jour, on aura pas de moyens
de remonter pour savoir ce qu'était
l'univers avant.
*jingle très funky*
Voilà, vous en savez déjà beaucoup sur
la gravité quantique à boucles,
il faut quand même retenir deux choses : la première, c'est que ça n'est qu'une tentative parmi d'autres,
et la deuxième, c'est que tout est loin
d'être complètement achevé dans cette théorie.
Il y a encore plein de choses
qu'on comprend pas et un certain nombre
de choses qui, sur le plan mathématique,
ne sont pas mises sur des bases solides.
Et puis de toute façon à la fin, ce sont
quand même les résultats expérimentaux
qui trancheront et qui permettront de
dire si la théorie est correcte ou pas.
D'ailleurs oui, parlons-en des résultats expérimentaux : sur quoi on va se baser pour vérifier cette théorie ?
Et bah la première chose dont on peut
se servir, c'est justement de la cosmologie.
Vous savez peut-être que la meilleure
preuve du scénario du Big Bang c'est
le rayonnement du fond diffus cosmologique -
qu'on appelle parfois le "rayonnement fossile".
Et dans la manière dont ce rayonnement
fluctue, on peut espérer trouver
des traces des premiers instants du Big Bang.
On est encore loin de pouvoir les
discerner, mais récemment Abhay Ashtekar
et un physicien français,
Aurélien Barrau,
ont réalisé des calculs pour essayer
de comprendre quels seraient les signes de
la gravité quantique à boucles dans le
rayonnement fossile.
Et c'est assez intéressant du point de
vue de la philosophie des sciences,
parce que ça veut dire que cette théorie,
on peut la tester expérimentalement,
elle fait des prédictions - même si aujourd'hui
on n'a pas encore la précision nécéssaire.
L'autre moyen d'aller tester la théorie
de la gravité quantique à boucles,
ce serait d'aller sonder la structure
de l'espace-temps.
La situation, elle est assez proche de ce
qu'on a avec la matière ordinaire.
Si je prends un caillou et que je le regarde avec
mes yeux ou même avec un microscope,
et bien il a l'air lisse, il a l'air fait de
matière continue.
Mais si je lui balance des rayons très
énergétiques, comme des rayons x,
j'arrive à détecter sa structure discrète, son organisation en cristal, je vois ses atomes en quelque sorte.
Et il pourrait se passer la même chose
avec la structure discrète de l'espace-temps :
si des rayons suffisamment énergétiques la traversent,
ils pourraient nous renseigner sur ces
fameux atomes d'espace.
Alors le problème, c'est que des rayons
aussi puissants, on ne sait pas en fabriquer,
mais ils peuvent se produire dans
certains phénomènes astrophysiques et
donc on a peut-être une chance de
capter des rayonnements très très
énergétiques qui portent en eux une
signature de la structure quantique de l'espace-temps.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, si elle
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à la partager,
histoire qu'on ne parle pas toujours
que la théorie des cordes.
Comme souvent j'écris un petit billet
qui accompagne cette vidéo et qui vous
donnera quelques détails. Même si
forcément je ne vais pas pouvoir tout expliquer.
Si vous aimez la physique fondamentale,
j'ai pleins d'autres vidéos sur la chaîne
qui en parlent. J'ai déjà
parlé de Stephen Hawking, j'ai parlé de
la théorie des cordes, de la mécanique
quantique, des trous noirs, de la
constante cosmologique, de l'intrication
quantique, etc.
Une petite chose qu'il faut je
précise avant qu'on m'en accuse c'est que
je suis un petit peu partisan de cette
histoire de gravité quantique à boucles
versus la théorie des cordes,
puisque en fait j'ai travaillé dans la
gravité quantique à boucles,
c'était mon sujet de thèse et j'ai eu la chance
de travailler avec une partie
des personnes dont j'ai parlé dans cette vidéo.
Pour ceux qui voudraient me rencontrer en vrai,
je peux vous annoncer déjà que je serai le
mercredi 5 octobre à l'Espace des Sciences
à Rennes pour donner une
conférence dans la salle Hubert Curien
donc voilà ça va être l'occasion de se voir là-bas.
Comme toujours vous pouvez retrouver les
actus de la chaîne sur facebook et twitter
et vous pouvez me souvenir sur Tipee.
Merci à tous et à bientôt !